ce
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport numéro 28 c'est parti pour un
nouveau tour de l'actualité sport du
département ils sont passés tout près de
l'exploit ce week end en demi finale de
division 2 les cougars se sont inclinés
dans un cinquième match décisif après
avoir remonté un handicap de deux
manches au cours de ce sept huit sports
nous vous ferons découvrir le trial vous
le voyez à l'image cette discipline où
l'équilibré le maître mot à l'occasion
de l'open organisé par le club de
voisins-le-bretonneux ce week-end et
nous allons vous plonger dans la
préparation d'avant-saison des féminines
de l'aes montigné rugby après la fin de
l'entente avec fois ci la saison
dernière les animaux tels veulent
retrouver l'élite évidemment en fin
d'émission tous les résultats du
week-end
mais tout d'abord place aux premiers
entretiens de ce sept huit sports j'en
parlais dans les titres nous nous allons
évoquer le trial une discipline un petit
peu méconnu et ce week-end voisin trial
zone le club de voisins-le-bretonneux
organise un open l'open des yvelines
c'est la première compétition de ce type
dans le département depuis bien
longtemps pierrick gens courent vous en
êtes le président bonsoir à vous quel
principe tout d'abord du trial ces
disciplines un petit peu un petit peu
méconnu le principe du trial c'est
d'évoluer sur des zones un petit peu
accidenté donc des rochers des gros
tronc qui sont placés en zone est
dévolue à vélo et il ne faut absolument
pas mettre le pied au sol c'est surtout
à la règle on va dire primordial la
règle d'or c'est il faut poser le monde
pied possible et comment étant jugé lors
d'une compétition comme ça va se
dérouler ce week-end l'hypothèse voisins
donc alors en compétition
nous traçons plusieurs zones où pour
tous niveaux donc de débutants experts
élite et chaque chaque niveau va devoir
emprunter un passage dans la zone
symbolisée par des flèches de couleurs
et il va devoir poser le monde y est
possible comme je le disais quand le
pilote pose un pied on comptabilise un
point quand le pilote poser deux pieds
d'un coup on comptabilise 5 points et au
bout de cinq points le coureur est
éliminé de la zone tout simplement donc
le but c'est vraiment ne pas mettre pied
à terre en fin de compte un simple
celui qui viennent csu qui ont marqué le
monde points à la fin de la compétition
les ce sont des pilotes en fin de compte
c'est comme ça qu'on les surnomme les
pratiquants de trial c'est des
spécialistes de l'équilibré il faut
avoir vraiment une notion d' équilibre
pour parfaite parce qu'on est toujours
sur la corde raide sur sur un film c'est
beaucoup de technique c'est beaucoup
d'apprentissage donc de plusieurs années
5 6 7 en 10 ans on apprend petit à petit
d'abord on apprend à tenir les qu'il
brosse à la prend au monde sur un en
obstacle vous avez commencé avec les
l'âge vous par exemple dix ans et là
vous en avez combien si c'est un des
nôtres donc très 13 en pratique vous
arrivez à quel niveau à l'heure actuelle
au niveau difficulté des zones
valiant j'ai un petit niveau national
parce qu'entre les breaks que je fais
les études et tous un petit fils de
corréler le niveau compétition mais en
général en 7 8 ans on arrive à un niveau
national très bon si on en fait tous les
régulièrement tous les week-ends pour
revenir sur cet open qui va se dérouler
ce week-end du côté de deux voisins je
crois qu'il va y avoir des grands noms
du trial et des grands noms français qui
vont être présents exactement donc on
aura la chance d'avoir la présence de
monsieur vincent hermance champion du
monde depuis
encore champion du monde depuis quelques
semaines seulement de trois semaines
donc il nous fera l'honneur de sa
présence ainsi que quelques autres
élites
le trial on a l'impression c'est un
monde un petit peu petit enfin content
parce que pas très médiatisé c'est le
cas
sur internet ça commence à grossir un
peu mais c'est vrai qu'on est on est un
peu en connu dans le milieu en dépôt de
jeux olympiques notre championnat du
monde personne n'a entendu parler et on
est un peu des fantômes mais oui le
milieu est petit on arrive à garder
contact assez facilement des plaques
facile avec les professionnels avec les
coureurs de grand de haut niveau et dans
un sport aussi fermée entre guillemets
c'est difficile de faire venir les
jeunes aujourd'hui vers le trial ou pas
c'est assez difficile parce que les
jeunes connaissent pas forcément la
pratique ou pense que c'est inaccessible
parce que quand on voit ça sur internet
on va tout de suite dé des pilotes qui
font des figures de folie il les parents
généralement un peu peur on est on peut
perdre ce que justement eux aussi voient
ces vidéos rassurez-vous jouera c'est
pas dangereux quand même on est juste
avec un vélo sur quelques obstacles
douce raison que j'en fais je me suis
jamais rien cassé le nez sur importante
dans la location vos envois en trial
zone jamais personne ne s'est fait mal
aux seins ou de tirs tour de de
temps en temps on met du protège tibia
mais les casques oui vous êtes quand
même la protéger quand vous êtes en
situation voilà on est protégé et les
accidents sont très très très rare outre
cette notion d' équilibre l'aspect
important sur le trial c'est plutôt le
matériel en fait je crois que vous avez
des vélos qui sont un petit peu
particulier à des vélo sans selle donc
c'est toujours la grande vague rendre
marco vélo ils sont ils ont pas de sel
je vous l'appliquez où vous le voulez
pour quelle raison de la selle pour
alléger déjà parce que l'on n'a aucune
utilité
d'avoir une selle et ça favorise le fait
que lui les cadres soit tronquée du coup
à leur moitié ça favorise les mouvements
on peut faire passer aux gens par dessus
les genoux pour l équilibre on est
beaucoup plus libre de s'exprimer sur
son vélo et je crois que vous excusant
beaucoup sur votre vélo d'ailleurs vous
êtes venu avec je vous propose d'aller
chercher il n'est pas très loin derrière
et caméras voilà poussé histoire votre
votre tabouret et on va essayer de faire
une petite démonstration de ce qu'est le
bas le trial en fait sur une zone de
compétition essayez de vous rapprocher
un petit peu pour qu'on vous voir voilà
parfait donc ça fait un petit peu vous
évidemment c'est les freins parfois donc
sa saison jean royer ans
notre table a survécu c'est parfait
merci beaucoup pierre-yves belle
démonstration on voit que c'est une
belle une belle notion d' équilibre qui
vous avez en tout cas merci beaucoup
puis arrivée en tout cas nous allons
passer tout de suite au baseball j'en
parlais en titre la semaine dernière
nous évoquions la double défaite des
cougars dans leur demi-finale aller de
la division 2 face à pessac dos au mur
les inhumant teint ne devait plus perdre
pour espérer voir la finale nous avons
suivi leur préparation cette semaine et
ce match retour couperet avec jonathan
minh mân
après le froid de cet hiver et la longue
interruption de l'été avant les playoffs
les organismes unis montrent un semble
usée mais à quelques jours d'une demi
finale retour décisive arnaud faux
l'entraîneur des couguars préfère
oublier la déception du match aller et
va tout faire pour remobiliser ses
joueurs tout le monde peut-être un petit
peu fatigué oui mais une finale ça ça
vaut le coup
les re motiver on peut pas motiver
quelqu'un qui ne l'est pas mais assure
qu'ils sont tous un petit peu motivés se
consumait essaie de faire c'est de les
allumer la petite flamme tison
au match aller cette petite flamme avait
quitté lésigny montant manquant
d'agressivité de précision ils se sont
inclinés par deux fois pessac les demi
finales de division 2 se joue au
meilleur des cinq matches les cougars ne
doivent plus perdre pour espérer voir la
finale est complètement de hauts murs à
il faut gagner trois matches tant que
c'est pas fini on est encore là on a
joué chez heures on va jouer chez nous
on a quand même quelques jalili retour
maintenant on a quelques points de notre
côté quand même la survie des cougars
passe d'abord par un premier match
couperet ce samedi après midi pour ne
pas vivre une fin de saison
cauchemardesque
dès les premiers lancés le sort
s'acharne sur les cougars en plus du
handicap de deux matchs à remonter des
trombes d'eau s'abattent sur jean
maréchal la rencontre doit être
interrompu les cougars vont devoir jouer
trois manches sur une journée quasiment
du jamais vu le lendemain gonflées comme
des cocottes minutes lésigny montant
s'impose finalement dans ce premier
match 12.12 bis repetita dans la seconde
rencontre 13,2 en faveur des joueurs
d'arnaud faut les omon s'enchaînent et
tout le peuple saint quentinois croit
alors à l'exploit mais les plus garante
à mal ce match décisif et dans la
huitième manche un défenseur de pessac
réalise un catch magnifique qui donne la
victoire aux panthères 6,5 la marche de
la finale aura été trop haute pour les
animaux teint qui pourront regretter
longtemps leurs ratés du match aller
et avant de passer au golf je tenais à
remercier pour cette belle démonstration
qui arrive merci beaucoup et on a vu
encore une fois ce qu'on peut faire avec
un vélo trial et juste rendez vous une
dernière fois pour pour cet open de
trial dimanche c'est ça dimanche donc le
dimanche sont deux donc dimanche
prochain la compétition va débuter à peu
près vers 10 heures du matin donc les
pilotari vaut entre 9h 9h30 le départ
est prévu à 10 heures et la remise des
récompenses à 4 heures donc pour vous
c'est vrai avoue un breton rue de la
remise donc les gens nous assume
toujours au terrain de bmx pour ceux qui
connaissent le cran c'est juste à côté
voilà où est la villa dans la rue de la
lys très bien merci beaucoup pierre-yves
pour cette belle démonstration et pour
si vous voulez donc suivre cet open au
trial rendez vous dimanche à un voisin
merci beaucoup merci passons désormais
au golf j'en parlais en début d'émission
ce week-end le golf isabella de plaisir
va recevoir une étape qualificative du
trophée philippe chatrier une
compétition ouverte à tous avaleur
caritatives
patrick krauss vous en êtes le vice
président de cette fondation bonsoir à
vous bonsoir vous organisés cette année
la 12e édition du trophée chatrier
comment est né ce trophée avec un nom
assez particulier on connait bien rester
à l'ombre particulier effet le nom
philippe chatrier tous les tous les
joueurs de tennis connaissent philippe
chatrier qui était président de la
fédération de tennis ça a été aussi un
très grand président de fédération je
crois que tout le tous les sports
reconnaissent que vit le chatrier tu es
un grand président il est mort
malheureusement de la maladie
d'alzheimer et son fils a créé la
fondation philippe chatrier pour aider
la recherche est vraiment allé dans le
sens de la recherche et donc du coup
vous avez créé deux compétitions une
compétition de tennis et cette
compétition de golf pour le golf comment
ça se passe c'est ouvert à tous a priori
c'est ça et on est en équipe oui enfin
c'est ouvert à tous et vous dire parce
que ça dépend des golfs qui nous
reçoivent certains golfs ne veulent
recevoir que leurs membres auquel cas
c'est pas ouvert à tous mais il demande
un droit d'entrée qui est reversée aux
trophées chatrier et c'est le trophée
reçu chatrier reversés à la fondation
contre contre contre la maladie
d'alzheimer il ya d'autres golfs qui
reçoivent tout le monde donc vous payez
ce que vous payez vava la recherche
contre l'autre contre la mode et
designer ça veut dire qu'en fin de
compte si on en est pas compétiteurs
aguerris le golf qu'on n'a pas de
handicap on peut quand même tenté sa
chance sur une des étapes des trophées
tout à fait comment se qualifie ton dont
il ya treize étapes qualificatives je le
disais la finale est à chantilly le 4
octobre comment se qualifie c'est les
cinq premiers de chaque étape il ya un
an bien définis dans chaque étape dans
le golfe il ya des résultats qui sont ce
qu'on appelle brut c'est à dire que
celui qui fait le meilleur de tout le
monde est qualifié il ya des résultats
nets c'est à dire vous avez des
handicaps il ya des champions il y en a
qui sont moins champions c'est l'intérêt
du golfe vous pouvez jouer donc vous
avez un classement qui vous permet de
lutter contre les champions donc ce
serait ce résultat net ces résultats
avec le classement avec selon handicap
donc on peut arriver à se qualifier
c'est les deux premiers qui sont
qualifiés un brut 1 est les équipes vont
jouer en scramble ce week-end
expliquez-nous un petit peu cette règle
parce que les règles de golf sur les
matchs par équipe c'est un petit peu un
peu spécifique je crois que c'est la
formule la plus disons la plus facile à
jouer là parce que vous jouez tout le
monde joue quelques mois en supposant
que je ne savent pas jouer je joue avec
un champion on joue tous les deux on
prend le meilleur cours et on rejoue du
maître du meilleur coût donc c'est le
bon joueur ne veut pas être gêné et le
mauvais joueur apprend quelque chose
parce que toute façon il peut aider le
bon joueur bon bah on joue chacun et
après on prend le meilleur l'on rejoue
les passionnés de golf qui viennent sur
ces étapes qualifié d' être
qualificative pardon dans leur
inscription peuvent faire un don en fait
à cette association et parfois je crois
que vous avez des surprises à un petit
peu oui tout à fait normalement le golf
demande un droit d'entrée pour jouer
chaque compétition qui n'est pas
forcément très élevé mais il précise que
comme c'est pour lui une cible pour le
une épreuve caritatives on peut donner
plus et certaines personnes se
permettent de donner plus qu'il est ce
qu'on apprécie beaucoup ça ça regroupe
beaucoup de joueurs chaque année ce
trophée philippe chatrier sur l'année ça
fait pas loin de 1500 personnes quand
même donc ça s'il ya beaucoup de
golfeurs qui aiment cette formule du
scramble aussi peut-être parce que c'est
une formule qui est quelque chose en
plus populaire dans les tournages c'est
très ludique c'est vraiment très ludique
c'est ça tout le monde jouée avec
beaucoup de facilité
en termes de dons vous récoltez
quelles sommes à peu près chaque année
ça dépend ça dépendra quand même cette
année là
en 2013 on a donné deux bourses de 30000
euros pour deux chercheurs qui sont
allés aux états unis fait refaire faire
des recherches c'est quand même ça quand
même verve a commencé à faire de
l'argent mais vous le disiez philippe
chatrier est décédé en 2000 donc il y à
il ya 13 ans est important de
commémorer un petit peu sa mémoire et
tout ce qu'il a fait pour le sport à
travers cette fondation je pense que
c'est très important c'était vraiment
quelqu'un de très très particulier j'ai
raconté de beaucoup de sportifs qu'ils
l'ont rencontré et qui ont dit après
l'avoir rencontrée que leur vie n'avait
pas changé mais il y avait quelque chose
de plus et donc du coup pour les pour
les sportifs les golfeurs est guéri
rendez vous ce dimanche c'est ça du côté
du golf isabella il a plaisir à partir
de 8h30 un faut se lever tôt pour pour
le nez par le premier départ en tout cas
révélé bah oui merci beaucoup patrick
d'être venu sur notre plateau et donc
rendez-vous ce week-end pour pour
quelques swings en tout cas je remercie
pour lutter contre la maladie
d'alzheimer
après une montée en fédérale une les
féminines de l'aes montigny rugby ont
cessé leur entente avec poissy cet été
elles repartent de vie divisions plus
bas avec la volonté de retrouver les
villes d'élite le plus vite possible
jonathan vilma n'a initié sa caméra dans
les coulisses dans leur préparation
d'avant saison
c'est par là que le chemin vers la
montée doit passer pendant deux jours
les joueuses de l'ice montigny rugby ont
accumulé les kilomètres en forêt les
exercices de placage de percussions et
mises au point les combinaisons enfants
semblent amener des joueuses un niveau
homogène le plus rapidement possible
puisqu'on à niveau intermédiaire des
confirmés des débutantes donc il faut
tendre à ramener tout le monde au même
niveau assez rapidement la saison
dernière les signé monteyne avait réussi
l'exploit de monter en fédérale une mais
l'entente avec poissy s'est arrêtée
résultats nets signés a été relégué en
fédérale 3 les saint-quentinoises
veulent retrouver leur place en
championnat de france pour cela elles
pourront s'appuyer sur un pack d'avants
très solide une charnière expérimentée
qui a connu le haut niveau et sur leur
solidarité on est un petit bourg ou pas
assez soudé donc certaines filles ça
fait déjà quelques années pour jouer
ensemble
et assez soudé on a une bonne bonne
ambiance on se fait bayard soir on a
fait une soirée ensemble et maintenant
ça se passe toujours très bien avec le
renfort de quatre jeunes joueuses à
l'intersaison montigny semble armé pour
voir les playoffs de fédérale 3 la
saison dernière les filles de denis
fleurot n'ont connu la défaite qu'à une
seule reprise
allez on passe en résultats du week-end
place tout d'abord au football une fois
n'est pas coutume ce week-end les
championnats faisaient une pause 1 pour
laisser place au premier tour de la
coupe des yvelines pour son deuxième
match de la saison montigny recevait par
mon loup sienne l'écart de trois
divisions se voit très vite et les unit
montain ça c'est d'abord les résultats
d'ensemble de cette journée de coupe des
yvelines vous voyez sur l'ensemble des
matchs de nombreux saint quentinois et
était d'en engager ses parts à vous
revient sur les images du coup de du
match de montigny l'écart de trois
divisions se voit très vite sur le
terrain lésigny montain envers marque
par deux fois en première période au
retour des vestiaires des saint
quentinois semble gérer leur avance mais
à l'heure de jeu l'ailier look siennois
réduit le score sur cette superbe frappe
croisée à ras de terre en fin de match
les jaune et noir auront beau pousser
pour égaliser mais la défense innée
montaigne un beau score final 2 1 je
vous propose d'écouter la réaction du
président unis montrent un didier mau
l'air satisfait de la prestation de ses
joueurs et qui espère rapporter le
trophée à montigny cette saison il ya
aucun souci au niveau 2
la qualité au niveau des
l'envi ensuite on a fait un peu tourner
en deuxième mi temps et on était moins
notre place et ils ont poussé donc ce
qui m'a plu dans le match et c'est que
justement on a fait un match sérieux un
peu relâchement en deuxième mi temps la
victoire est là c'est l'essentiel on va
l'ambition c'est d'aller le plus loin
possible puis il a gagné bien sûr on va
revenir cette fois ci aux principaux
résultats les autres matches de ce
premier tour de nombreux club saint
quentinois était engagé je le disais
quasiment que des victoires à domicile
vous le voyez à noter la large victoire
de guyancourt 5-2 face à besné le carton
d'elancourt à domicile face à houdan 6-0
sont passés à la trappe voisins le
bretonneux après la séance de tirs au
but 6 à 5 face à bali noisy ou encore
trappe face à andrésy chez les féminines
c'est toujours du football deuxième
journée de division de montigny s'est
fait étriller littéralement à domicile
5-0 par vendenheim candidat à la montée
en élite c'est la deuxième défaite
consécutive pour les joueuses de
jordanie grosset qui sont désormais
lanterne rouge de ce groupe à en rugby
ce week-end le championnat de france de
fédérale 3 reprenait ses droits pour
cette première journée plaisir
accueillez l'union des bords de marne au
stade robert barran et le persée s'est
facilement imposé 28 5 avec trois essais
inscrits les joueurs de philippe behar
lance idéalement leur saison handball
les féminines de l'aes montigny
reprenait le chemin des terrains
également ce week-end avec leur premier
tour de coupe de france les joueuses de
stéphane ce paysan ce sont de se
déplacer à villiers pensionnaire de
nationale 3 la division d'écart c'est
vite ressenti au score victoire facile
47 à 24 une bonne préparation pour leur
premier match de championnat ce week-end
à plouvorn on passe au basket maintenant
la saison de national elle reprend ce
week-end vous avez suivi la préparation
des féminines de l'entente le chesnay
versailles il ya quelques semaines en
match amical ce jeudi les joueuses de
stéphane relais recevait le stade
français se sont imposés sur le fil 57 à
passons désormais au cyclisme le dossier
qui nous tient en haleine depuis
plusieurs mois évidemment c'est le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
nous connaissons enfin la date
d'inauguration le nouveau clairefontaine
du cyclisme ouvrira ses portes le 30
janvier 2014 vous pouvez d'ores et déjà
coché cette date nous vous montrions il
ya quelques semaines les premières
images de la pose de la piste une
structure unique en europe 1 longue de
250 mètres avec une inclinaison plus
importante qu'ailleurs de 44 degrés
l'anneau du vélodrome est déjà surnommée
la piste aux records et la fédération
française et l'équipe de france
s'installeront à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines derrière le
vélodrome il y aura aussi une arène de
bmx couverte et qui est en train de voir
le jour également avec cette ouverture
le vélodrome devrait pouvoir accueillir
les prochains championnats de france sur
piste tout début de l'année en 2014 un
projet dont le budget s'élève environ à
70 millions d'euros pour finir un
dernier quelques dernières images de
l'opération sentez vous sport si vous
voulez découvrir certains sports comme
la peteca par exemple ou tester vos
capacités physiques dirigez-vous ce
week-end à la base de loisirs pour la
deuxième édition vous ne serez pas
obligé de vous inscrire dans un club par
la suite mais cela vous permettra de
comprendre l'importance de l'activité
physique quotidienne avec deux mille
quatre cent visiteurs l'an dernier
l'événement montre que les saint
quentinois et bien sont plus sportif que
la moyenne
avant une pratique sportive régulière
pas forcément d'ailleurs
au niveau pas forcément en club de façon
compétitive et etam et avoir une
pratique sportive régulière ça permet
d'éliminer une bonne partie des
bactéries qu'on peut attraper des
maladies comme le rattrape et c'est donc
c'est vraiment très important de
sensibiliser les gens à ça on s'est
rendu compte que la population qui
venait sur sentez vous sport était un
peu plus sportive que la moyenne
nationale
et si vous voulez découvrir toutes ces
activités sportives rendez vous samedi
et dimanche entre 14h et 18h à la base
de loisirs j'en parlais tout à l'heure
pendant l'émission nous avons suivi la
préparation d'avant-saison des féminines
de l'aes montigny rugby elles ont cessé
leur entente avec poissy cet été elles
repartent deux divisions plus bas on
fédérale 3 avec la volonté de retrouver
les vies l'élite le plus vite possible
jonathan vilma naimi c'est sa caméra
dans les coulisses de leur préparation
c'est par là que le chemin vers la
montée doit passer pendant deux jours
les joueuses de l'aes montigny rugby ont
accumulé les kilomètres en forêt les
exercices de placage de percussions et
mises au point les combinaisons sont
centraux amener des joueuses un niveau
homogène le plus ardent passé puisqu'on
à niveau intermédiaire des confirmés des
débutantes donc il faut tendre à ramener
tout le monde au même niveau assez
rapidement
la saison dernière les signé monteyne
avait réussi l'exploit de monter en
fédérale une mais l'entente avec poissy
s'est arrêtée résultats montigny a été
relégué en fédérale 3 les
saint-quentinoises veulent retrouver
leur place en championnat de france pour
cela elles pourront s'appuyer sur un
pack d'avants très solide une charnière
expérimentée qui a connu le haut niveau
et sur leur solidarité on est un petit
groupe à se souder donc certaines vies
ça fait déjà quelques années pour jouer
ensemble donc on est et acea assez soudé
on a une bonne bonne ambiance on se fait
bayard soir on a fait une soirée
ensemble
maintenant ça se passe toujours très
bien avec le renfort de quatre jeunes
joueuses à l'intersaison montigny semble
armé pour voir les playoffs de fédérale
3 la saison dernière les filles de doni
fleurot n'ont connu la défaite qu'à une
seule reprise
et pour terminer un saut 7,8 sports
place à l'agenda du week-end prochain
vous en avez l'habitude maintenant avant
de ranger vos boules de pétanque pour
l'hiver vous pourrez pointer ou tirer
une dernière fois en doublettes ce
samedi 21 au lac de la sorte de riz du
côté de voisins-le-bretonneux dès 9h30
inscriptions possibles sur place ou sur
internet côté championnat on suit
évidemment les féminines de l'entente
chesnay versailles vous pourrez voir et
assister à leur reprise ce week-end face
à saint paul rose et rendez vous ce
samedi à 20 heures au gymnase bel air
pour leur premier match de national une
au chesnay et si vous voulez voir des
professionnels de la balle jaune
s'affronter cette semaine vous pourrez
aller du côté du tennis club de plaisir
qui accueille et organise évidemment son
traditionnel tournoi future atp dont les
finales se joueront ce dimanche
après-midi pour rappel l'année dernière
c'était marc gicquel le français qui
l'avait remporté merci beaucoup de nous
avoir suivis pour ce nouveau 7,8 sport
qui touche à sa fin vous pouvez réagir
sur les réseaux sociaux et twitter avec
le hashtag le 7-8 sport tout attaché
bonne soirée et à lundi prochain